G
TIRELESSLY, TO BRING FORMER
STUDENT, SAFELY, TO ITALY.
>> TEACHER, AND STUDENT,
MEANING AGAIN.
>> WELCOME, WELCOME, WELCOME TO
ITALY.
>> SHE FOUNDED, AND RANA,
SCHOOL IN KABUL.
WHERE SHE GRADUATED, 5 YEARS
AGO.
LAST MONTH, AS THE TALIBAN TOOK
OVER KABUL, THEY RECEIVED A
DESPERATE MESSAGE FROM A FORMER
STUDENT.
DON'T ABANDON ME.
>> THIS IS A UNIQUE SPACE --
>> SHE FOUNDED THE STORY
ACADEMY OF 2013, WITH FUNDS SHE
WON FROM THE ROLEX AWARD, FOR
ENTERPRISE.
THE ACADEMY, USING
AFGHANISTAN'S AGE OLD ORAL
TRADITIONS, AS A MEANS OF
EDUCATION.
>> SHE TOLD ME, SHE WAS VERY
HAPPY.
>> MORE THAN 5000 KILOMETERS
FROM KABUL, PULLING EVERY
STRING SHE COULD, TO WRANGLE
PLACES FOR HER FORMER STUDENTS,
AND THEIR FAMILIES, ON ITALIAN
MILITARY, FLIGHTS OUT OF THE
AFGHAN CAPITAL.
HER, AND HER FAMILY, MADE IT
THROUGH THE PANDEMONIUM, AND ON
TO A PLANE.
THEY, ARE NOW, IN A SMALL TOWN
IN SOUTHERN ITALY.
ANOTHER FORMER STUDENT, AND HIS
FAMILY, WERE ABLE TO GET ON A
FLIGHT OUT, BUT BARELY.
>> SHE TEXTED ME, AND ASKED ME
TO SEND HER THE LIST OF FAMILY
MEMBERS, HE RECALLS.
THE NEXT DAY, SHE ASKED ME TO
GO TO THE AIRPORT TO 5 IN THE
MORNING.
WE LEFT ALL OF OUR BELONGINGS,
AND PROPERTY, BEHIND.
SO, WHEN I SAW THE SITUATION AT
THE AIRPORT I THOUGHT, WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GET IN.
THE TALIBAN WERE FIRING.
IT BARELY MISSED ME.
THE ITALIAN GOVERNMENT,
MANAGING TO EVACUATE NEARLY
5000 AFGHANS, BEFORE THE
TALIBAN TOOK CONTROL OF THE
AIRPORT.
THEY LOOK BACK ON THE LAST
MONTH WITH MIXED EMOTIONS.
>> ON THE ONE HAND, I'M VERY
RELIEVED THAT THEY ARE HERE,
AND THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO COME
TO ITALY, BUT, I AM VERY
WORRIED ABOUT EVERYONE ELSE,
WHO COULD NOT LEAVE THE
COUNTRY.
SO, MY THOUGHT IS ALSO WITH
THEM.
>> BARELY A MONTH IN ITALY, SHE
MOURNS THE LIFE SHE LOST.
>> I LOVE MY COUNTRY, I LOVE MY
PEOPLE, AND I HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS IN MY COUNTRY.
SO, I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO THEM.
IT MAKES ME SO SAD.
>> AHEAD, NO LYING THE
STRANGERS TO ADAPT TO A